new research shows a deadly flu virus
spreads more easily they easily than
previously thought
at least 240 schools nationwide are
closed today to try to stop the virus
from spreading at one Wisconsin School
30% of the students were absent this
week because of the epidemic nationwide
more than 4500 deaths have now been
linked to the flu this season our doctor
Tara Narula spoke with a researcher who
says the flu can spread just by
breathing we all gotta breathe so that's
scary Jerry good morning good morning
Gail researchers at the University of
Maryland have created a one-of-a-kind
device that collects virus samples from
your breath using that data they then
track how the flu is transmitted from
person to person
all you do is sit breathe and let the
machine do the work
it just is pulling all of the air from
around your face at a fast enough rate
that we collect everything but not so
fast that it feels like there's a breeze
it's called the gesundheit - and is the
brainchild of University of Maryland
professor dr. Donald Milton the device
is being used to collect and analyze the
flu virus in an exhaled breath with
those virus samples researchers are
trying to track down how the flu spreads
the focus has always been on telling
people well coughing and sneezing is how
its transmitted in 2014 MIT used
high-speed imaging to study just how far
coughing sneeze droplets and therefore
germs can spread but in a CDC study
earlier this year researchers discovered
that the flu virus can be transmitted
simply by breathing if we understand
better how much of the infection is
transmitted by air and what the dose in
the air is we can then figure out how to
reduce your exposure there using student
volunteers to study the mechanics of how
the bug spreads by swabbing people who
come in contact with infected students
if I can show that you've got the flu
from him and it didn't come from his
nose but it came from his lung then you
got it by the airborne route we got the
answer there hoping to use these
findings to create models for better
ventilation systems that would make it
harder for the flu and other dangerous
viruses to spread for now wash your
hands for at least 20 seconds sneeze
into your elbow and please stay home if
you're sick
thanks to her